you're getting married so I want to say
something and I want congratulations by
the way congratulations nobody else
gives a [ __ ] but I want to say something
very important first of all who is the
person who planned the party here
tonight thank you for not putting dick
hats on everybody I am very happy zero
dick hats zero dick whistles and and you
and so and how long have you been dating
your fiance eight years there was a
little bit of [ __ ] stink on that
eight years did you hear that
eight years how long have you been
engaged two years just waiting for the
right time or what is a what what was
the weight of the two years just waiting
for the exact are you finishing law
school
[ __ ] congratulations holy [ __ ] and
what does he do he works in tech support
so he's unemployed
tech support that's that's another way
of saying I don't have a [ __ ] job I
he was like man I got a possum woman
who's in law school
tech support that is some [ __ ]
that's like saying I'm a digital
innovator eat dicks that doesn't mean
anything but I will tell you here's what
I love about seeing bachelorette parties
at comedy shows you know what I love
about it cuz it's girls night
it's girls night we're going crazy and
girls night hahaha
meanwhile mr. [ __ ] your fiance is
somewhere in Naples right now it's it's
in his face like this
but have a great night gave myself a
[ __ ] concussion for that joke you're
welcome
[Music]
you